bienvenue sur 9,7 catellier dans votre
émission vivre ensemble aujourd'hui nous
allons aborder le thème de l'accueil
familial avec madame qishan a marre
gestionnaire au département même rivière
accueillons deux familiales et mamou
rien accueilli chez madame rivière alors
entre le maintien à domicile et le
placement en établissement il ya une
solution intermédiaire c'est l'accueil
familial même qishan à main est ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer en quoi
consiste ce mode d'accueil
oui l'accueil familial consiste à
accueillir à titre onéreux une deux ou
trois personnes âgées et ou adultes en
situation de handicap et de leur offrir
un véritable projet de vie
alors dites nous qui peut être
accueillant familial alors toute
personne majeure seul ou en couple
motivé et présentant toutes les
garanties
et qui dispose d'un logement adapté peut
accueillir une personne âgée très bien
et qui peut être accueillis alors
peut-être accueillir des personnes âgées
de plus de 60 ans qui ne peut plus vivre
seule chez elle sans pour autant vouloir
vivre en établissement merci sont
également concernés par ce mode
d'accueil des personnes en situation de
handicap qui ne dispose plus d'autonomie
suffisante pour vivre seul ou qui n'ont
pas fait les demandes n'ont pas eu de
places en établissements 1 donc les
personnes âgées et les personnes en
situation de handicap sont concernés par
l'accueil famille à fait d'accord il
faut également noter que l'accueillît ne
doit avoir aucun lien de parenté avec la
colle en famille à un très important
accord même rivière
vous êtes accueillant de familial à
saint françois
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé pour exercer
son métier
ce qui m'a motivé c'est d'avoir été seul
moi même donc c'est vrai que je suis
jeune j'étais encore jeune donc je me
suis dit qu il fallait qu mans donc des
personnes qui
qui sont seuls qui sont abandonnées et
que je donne un peu d'amour je fais
venir ça a commencé comme ça ça peut
très bien combien de personnes est ce
que vous accueillir votre domicile ben j
des gammes de gamme d'accor et est-ce
que vous avez dû procéder à des
aménagements particuliers dans votre
logement oui qu'est ce que vous avez
fait par exemple bon bain et essayer de
mettre les chambres des malades plus
pris des sanitaires des acteurs pour
qu'ils sont pas de problème après bombay
a la cote
aussi il fallait marolleau jc époque
soit des plats ou qu'ils puissent se
déplacer c'est le coeur avant on a mûri
à se déplacer facilement parce qu'elle
est arrivé très jeune chez nous un bon
voilà comme que maintenant bombe avec
l'âge et au fur et à mesure donc en
fonction de son des grattements de vous
adapter à la d'accord bon ça fait très
longtemps alors qu'elle est chez vous
oui d'accord mais à mourir alors vous
êtes content benchenane rivière oui
c'est bien d'être dans une vraie famille
oui vous participez aux activités de
toute la famille oui
alors qu'est ce que vous faites la
journée racontez nous un petit peu long
mais yoann et ligue logique affleck en
fait coucou n'aime pas voir une équipe
rajeunie de golf café
oui des grains l'aigle royal comme tu
dis quoi
bah oui vous avez un peu même rivière ni
comme ça c'est pas un qui fait tout oui
après qu'est ce que vous faites dans la
journée
j'écoutais la télé la radio où elle
vécut les radios ah c'est ça que vous
aimez bien faire écouter la radio
oui d'accord après vous raconter ammann
rivière qu'est ce que vous avez entendu
via furie cours accueillent actuellement
deux personnes handicapées à son
domicile à saint-andré l'accueil
familial est une solution intermédiaire
entre le maintien à domicile et
l'hébergement en établissement
un mode d'accueil qui permet aux
personnes qui ne souhaitent aucune ne
peuvent plus vivre seul de bénéficier
d'un cadre de vie familiale et de mettre
fin à l' isolement
ce dispositif constitue une priorité du
conseil départemental dans sa politique
en faveur des personnes handicapées ou
madame furie cours devenir accueillant
familial s'est présentée à elle comme
une évidence
mwami pense pour devenir une famille
d'accueil c'est le côté humain
naturellement donc la communication
batum fait qu'on devait y déroulent de
tous les jours naturellement parce que
moi tu peux me fais avec mes accueilli
ben me calcule pas d'eau mais c'est tous
les jours il vient naturellement le
contact et puis comme mamie aime bien
mon métier donc pas moi qui fais ce
métier comme où travaillent y tient qu'à
lisbonne donc à vos cahiers les
courtisans qui fait déroule de la
journée donc s'ils n'ont pas indiqué que
le matin à québec en petit déjeuner donc
le midi donc ce que tu manges après la
sieste 15 café ak petits gâteaux et de
goûter et le twenty nine le conseil
départemental participe à l'aménagement
et à l'accessibilité du domicile
la collectivité met également en place
des formations initiales et continues à
destination des accueillants familiaux à
l'effet travaux parce que fallait fait
des ronds pour les fauteuils handicapé
pour les personnes en fauteuil et des
plans inclinés de haut niveau que parce
que la bd démarche escaliers pas les
supprimer et les barrières de sécurité
aussi oui voilà
de toute façon pas fait pour avoir mon
agrément fallait que me fait les travaux
dans les normes
véritable environnement familial
synonyme de partage et de solidarité
les accueils participent à la vie et aux
activités de la famille tarifs donc
voila vous collez le domaine vital
matane camp de transit de je n'ai appris
les aimait passer donc et après de
l'après midi que cette activité banale
chute de dominos mes cadeaux donc voilà
et après avec monsieur boulet lui aime
bien regarder la télé et monsieur klein
musique voilà après mr y arriver au nom
de dix planches lenovo par exemple lui a
pris bien soin aux cris de joie
voilà le programme à respirer la joie
limité ça fait leur numéro sur la
pelouse ça soit 210 java bleue bien me
rase pas là aussi vous savez monsieur
marc andré guyaux politique soit
savamment magie micro guitare amis mais
en anglais voilà exact où jour les
combats d'hier
ben voyons en bas de la paille et que la
paille devant un bar de l'europe albanie
le matin du match on y parle bali le
tram à la pension comme en été avant
devient le moment rien vaut mieux être
accueillant familial est un vrai métier
où sont requises de nombreuses qualités
telles que la patience l'écouté le
dialogue et la tolérance
alors même qu'ils cinéma dites nous
quelles sont les conditions à remplir
pour exercer métier d'accueillant
familiale alors l'autre exercer ce
métier il est obligatoire d'obtenir un
agrément du département cet agrément
délivré par la présidente du conseil
départemental et va là pour durer de
cinq ans et renouvelable très bien
l'agrément que la personne a reçu est ce
qui peut être remis en cause et dans
quelles conditions
oui en effet l'agrément peut être mis en
cause dans des situations de
maltraitance avérée lors d'abus
financiers et ou un manque de
collaboration de l'accueillant avec
équipes médico-sociales en charge du
suivi d'accord alors quelle mesure est
ce que le département prend pour éviter
que ces situations ne se produisent
alors pour que pour une telle situation
se reproduise
l'équipe médico social en charge du
suivi effectué des visites de manière
inopinée dit chez la personne et vérifie
si les conditions d'accueil sont
toujours réunis c'est les conditions
d'agrément sont respectés et c'est la
personne accueillie et bien traités même
rivière vous vous allez obtenir un
jugement massivement oui d'accord et
c'est un agrément individuels ou de
couples individus et ça m'a vraiment
individuel de votre mari vous êtes à
jour mène plus depuis qu'il est à la
retraite
d'accord à paris ces pratiques alors
vous exercer votre métier à domicile
donc vous mêler vie professionnelle et
vie privée
toute la journée comment ça se passe
comment vous gérez savent au quotidien
c'est une question d'adaptation
donc mes enfants étaient très jeunes ils
sont habitués une dix enfants bombay
sont nés là les malades les accueils
était déjà là donc bon dlc ça parce que
naturel voilà six familles roms en l1
c'est parfait alors vous avez quand même
une lourde responsabilité assurer le
bien-être sécurité la santé de la
personne accueillie ce n'est pas trop
lourd à gérer pour vous non non moi pour
moi en tout cas
bon ben c'est vrai que au début il
fallait apprendre tout simplement et
beaucoup de choses que confuse et nous
qui n'est pas forcément bien mais on m'a
avec des temps de formation à prendre
très bien alors justement même qui sonna
mans nous avons vu l'accueil familial
est un métier exigeant qu'est ce que le
département met en place pour
professionnaliser ses accueillant alors
lorsque l'accueillant a obtenu son
agrément
il est obligatoire de suivre une
formation initiale qui porte sur le
cadre réglementaire de l'accueil
familial et au cours des années
d'activité de laqueuille ans
nous le proposons nous proposons
également des formations continues sur
différents thèmes tels que
l'alimentation des personnes âgées les
maladies cardiovasculaires la prévention
des chutes accidentelles chez la
personne âgée et d'autres encore
d'accord on aimerait bien vous avez
suivi des formations vous oui et donc
vivant alors assez bien alors vision un
peu qu'est-ce que vous
suivi comme formation bon ben il ya pour
les premiers secours
après sa belle ben justement comme les
accidents cardiovasculaires 1
après bon vin comme de manière difficile
relation suivie des cheveux et l'un
d'eux mêmes la veille sur le handicap
fait bien fait sans heurts alors même
qu'ils sont l'âme actuellement l'offre
de places en famille d'accueil est elle
suffisante par rapport à la demande
oui tout à fait nous comptons
aujourd'hui 551 accueillants familiaux
agréés sur tout le territoire pour 1103
place donc ces plats sont surtout
disponible en zone rurale après bien non
donc nous aux gramounes sont bien oui et
un frère ils ont des plats très bien
expliqué nous quels sont les avantages
du métier d'accueillant familiale donc
tout d'abord je vais parler de
désavantage de la personne accueillie
donc la personne accueillie donc cet
accueil est moins onéreux qu'en
établissement
ça permet d'offrir à l'accueillir a lieu
de vie chaleureux sécurisant et qui lui
permet de maintenir des liens sociaux
des liens intergénérationnels et bien
sûr de vivre dans un cadre familial en
gardant les repères pour l'accueillant
familial
l'accueil familial est un véritable
métier qui permet à l'accueillons de
travailler à son domicile c'est ce qui
est un avantage
l'accueillant bénéficient de formations
pour se professionnaliser de congé et
rémunérés directement par l'accueillît
donc celle accueilli qui emploie
l'accueillons alors si vous aussi ce
métier très riche vous intéresse madame
qui sonne à ma va vous donner tout de
suite la démarche à suivre pour postuler
si vous souhaitez postuler pour devenir
accueillant familial vous adresser une
demande écrite à la présidente du
conseil départemental
dès que votre courrier arrive au service
départemental de l'accueil familial le
gestionnaire accuse réception de votre
demande et vous convie à une réunion
d'information sur le métier
d'accueillant familiale au cours de
cette réunion d'information animée par
des travailleurs sociaux notamment d'un
psychologue et d'un travailleur social
un assistant social ces personnes vous
explique en détail en quoi consiste le
métier d'accueillant familiale et vous
donne les conditions nécessaires pour
devenir accueillant familial à l'issue
de la réunion d'information un
formulaire est transmis aux postulants
afin qu'ils nous renseigne s'il souhaite
maintenir ou s'il a besoin d'un délai de
réflexion pour sa demande d'agrément au
cas où le candidat maintient sa demande
le gestionnaire en charge du suivi lui
transmet un dossier de demande
d'agrément a complété à renseigner et à
nous le retourner par lettre recommandée
avec accusé réception dès que ce dossier
arrêt chez nous et que le gestionnaire
déclare complet les travailleurs sociaux
commencent à évaluer les conditions
d'accueil de l'habitat et effet
également une évaluant ce une évaluation
sociale
à l'issue de ces évaluations les
travailleurs sociaux rédige un rapport
synthétique et émis un avis sur la
demande
pour tout renseignement vous pouvez
contacter le service départemental de
l'accueil familial au 02 62 90 35 58 de
8h30 à 15h30
et si vous souhaitez postuler dès à
présent adresser votre demande à la
présidente du conseil départemental à
l'adresse suivante conseil départemental
de la réunion direction des personnes
âgées et handicapées service
départemental de l'accueil familial de
rue de la source
481 pour famille alors notre émission sa
chair je remercie nos invités et je vous
donne rendez vous très bientôt sur mac
7,4 télé dans votre émission vivre
ensemble maxi
oh